a local homeowner association company
called
camco partnered with the girl scouts to
help lift spirits on national giving
hearts day
which was actually yesterday this was in
southern hills
the scouts delivered the handmade
valentine's cards they made cookies even
stuffed animals
to the residents at legacy house of
southern hills
this event had a personal connection for
the ceo of camco
my mother and my mother-in-law are both
residents
at legacy house and
through covid and the pandemic they have
been locked
in they they they
don't get to go out and do as much as
they normally did
so we're here to try and brighten their
spirits
and as well as the staff here they do
wonderful work and that was joe lust ceo
of camco
he says the event was successful for
everyone because the seniors had their
spirits lifted of course with all the
visitors and
the girl scouts who were struggling with
their cookies sale during the pandemic
certainly had a wonderful chance to
fundraise because who can pass up girl
scout cookies right christian that's
right and it's a win-win for everyone
i'm sure they were very happy to see
them and obviously the girl scouts
also very happy to be there that's for
sure